[Música]
los líderes de la política exterior de
rusia y la unión europea entregaron
conclusiones de su reunión en moscú
sérguei lávrov advierte contra la
degradación de las relaciones con la
unión europea mientras que josep borrell
pidió la liberación del opositor alexéi
navalni y todos los manifestantes
detenidos
el presidente de estados unidos joe
biden dio a conocer las prioridades que
tendrá en su política de exterior y
empezó por recalcar que la diplomacia ha
vuelto entre los anuncios está el fin
del apoyo a las operaciones ofensivas de
arabia saudita en yemen el aumento
histórico del límite de admisión anual
de refugiados y las relaciones con china
y rúsia
cerca de 13 millones de ecuatorianos
irán a las urnas el domingo 7 de febrero
para elegir nuevo presidente entre 16
candidatos el alto nivel de indecisos y
los pronósticos de los votos nulos
indican que la elección se decidirá en
una segunda vuelta a los favoritos son
andrés araus del correísmo y el
conservador guillermo lasso
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france24 blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos a moscú
rusia donde el alto representante para
la política exterior de la unión europea
josep borrell le dijo al ministro ruso
de exteriores serguéi lávrov que las
relaciones bilaterales con rusia están
en un punto bajo por el envenenamiento y
el encarcelamiento del líder opositor
ruso alexéi navalni y apeló a su
liberación por su parte lávrov afirmó
que rusia y la unión europea estaban en
desacuerdo por muchas cuestiones pero
que ambas partes habían expresado su
interés en establecer un diálogo más
amplio en las áreas en las que
estuvieron de acuerdo y es que según
borrell pese a las diferencias levantar
un muro de silencio no es una opción
escuchemos parte de estas declaraciones
de los ambos funcionarios hemos revisado
el estado de las relaciones entre rusia
y la unión europea es cierto que estas
relaciones atraviesan tiempos difíciles
hay muchos temas en los que tenemos
opiniones divergentes
entendemos que el mayor deterioro de las
relaciones podría estar plagado de
consecuencias negativas
en mi visita coincide con el arresto y
sentencia de navalny y el arresto de
miles de manifestantes estrechos
a word y autopista release hemos pedido
su liberación y pedido una investigación
sobre su envenenamiento
pasión y cambiamos ahora información y
pasamos a eeuu porque en su primer gran
discurso sobre asuntos exteriores como
presidente de ese país yo bailé anunció
la línea que su gobierno tendrá con el
mundo el aumento del límite de admisión
anual de refugiados mano dura con china
de rusia y el fin del apoyo a arabia
saudita en la guerra de yemen y detener
la retirada de las tropas de alemania
fueron algunos de estos puntos tratados
en los desafíos exteriores para conocer
más detalles de estos puntos salud en
ese momento cristóbal vázquez quien se
encuentra en la capital estadounidense
cristóbal muy buen día cuáles son los
detalles de estos puntos más fuertes
sobre la política exterior de la
administración en by the numbers
fue el primer discurso del presidente
joe biden en el departamento de estado
donde además le agradeció a sus
empleados de haber sostenido los últimos
cuatro años bajo el gobierno de donald
trump en su en sus puntos más relevantes
pues le pidió a rusia le pidió al
gobierno de putin que liberara
inmediatamente alexéi navalni y a los
manifestantes que piden su liberación
este es el líder opositor que ha
denunciado varios casos de corrupción en
rusia y pues también el secretario de
estado en línea con el discurso de joe
biden pide además que se vuelva al orden
democrático en rusia también yo bailén
pues se dice que va a poner mano dura a
la guerra económica que trata de librar
china con el mundo pone va a poner las
cartas sobre la mesa sobre qué tan
fuerte va a ser con esa potencia
diciendo que no le asusta lo que está
haciendo china y un punto importante
también resaltar es que
y su asesor para asuntos del hemisferio
occidental
juana gonzález ha dicho que con respecto
a cuba van a volver a rehabilitar los
viajes de estadounidenses a la isla y
también las divisas ahora a cristóbal en
otro tema el expresidente donaldson
afirmó que no testificara en su segundo
juicio político en el senado por los
hechos ocurridos el pasado 6 de enero en
el capitolio cómo se prepara la defensa
del ex presidente
claro y es que los encargados del
impeachment en el senado le enviaron una
carta a el expresidente donald trump
refiriéndole que fuera a testificar en
audiencia pública a los abogados les
respondieron inmediatamente los abogados
de donald trump una carta a los
administradores del impi diciéndole que
no que él es el ex presidente no se va a
presentar simplemente porque ellos no
creen que hubo delito porque no creen
específicamente que el presidente al
decir que leen como en el infierno en el
discurso antes de que los manifestantes
se tomaran el capitolio el 6 de enero
pues incitó entonces a que ellos se
tomaran el capitolio no hay conexión
dicen sus abogados ahí por ende es
inconstitucional la el juicio político
que tienen hacerle a donald trump y por
ende no se va a presentar dicen que
simplemente no tienen base y pues se
preparan entonces con el expresidente
alegando precisamente eso saben además
su defensa la defensa del expresidente
trump
van a comparar los demócratas con dos
tercios de los votos en el senado que se
necesita para aprobar el impeachment
cristóbal gracias por la información que
tengo ustedes de un feliz resto de día
continuamos en estados unidos la
republicana marcha liz taylor greene fue
apartada de sus labores en dos comités
de la cámara de representantes después
de que la mayoría demócrata en esa sala
votará por su salida es una sanción que
llega por los repetidos comentarios de
taylor win que defiende teorías
conspirativas que van desde que los
incendios en california son provocados
por un satélite espacial hasta dudar de
la veracidad de los atentados del 11 de
septiembre y de algunos tiroteos en
escuelas la historia de huang viales
un mes después de haberse posesionado el
congreso de eeuu llevó a cabo una
gestión sin precedentes una votación al
completo en la cámara de representantes
para pedir la salida de una de sus
legislaturas de un comité en este caso
en contra de la republicana mayoriteo
erwin de georgia que reconoce haber
entrado en política por la inspiración
que le dio el ex presidente de la cndh
trump
es una difusora de teorías falsas de
conspiración tales como qua non' que
habla de una red de pedofilia liderada
por los demócratas o de otras como la
que dice que los incendios forestales en
california son causados por un satélite
espacial con 230 votos a favor y 199 en
contra la cámara de representantes votó
para apartarla de sus cargos en los
comités de educación presupuesto y
trabajo la congresista green defendía la
ejecución de un líder de esta cámara
ella defendía la ejecución del ex
presidente barack obama alentaba la
violencia contra las fuerzas de la ley y
tiene un largo historial de comentarios
racistas antisemitas e islamofóbicos
ningún republicano defendió las palabras
de mayoría pero sólo 11 de ellos votaron
del lado demócrata una cifra que aunque
aparentemente pequeña evidencia cada vez
más las divisiones dentro de la
formación conservadora tras la salida
del ex presidente del tromp antes de la
votación ella se retractó de sus
comentarios pero no pidió perdón y estas
fueron palabras del pasado y estas cosas
no me representan no representan a mi
distrito y no representan mis valores de
una semana
la sanción contra maryuri es una
antesala del impeachment contra el ex
presidente del antro que comienza la
próxima semana y en donde una postura en
común de los republicanos será clave
para evitar el fin de la carrera
política del magnate ecuador elegirá a
un nuevo presidente este domingo 7 de
febrero los comicios se celebrarán con
16 candidatos pero las encuestas en ese
país andino destacan a dos como
favoritos uno de los cuales es apoyado
por el ex presidente rafael correa que
hoy vive en bélgica en el exilio un
programa de recuperación económica del
candidato araus de entregar mil dólares
a un millón de familias a causa de la
pandemia ha centrado el debate electoral
nuestro corresponsal gustavo ortega con
más información desde la capital
ecuatoriana
'ecuador revive la nostalgia en las
calles antes de las elecciones generales
del 7 de febrero el recuerdo de rafael
correa- aún está presente en algunos
ciudadanos que clavan la vuelta al
socialismo
andrés ser aus representa la tendencia
afín al expresidente correa un
economista de 35 años que implante a un
programa de ayuda social con la entrega
de mil dólares a un millón de familias
ecuatorianas ante la pérdida del 40% de
los ingresos a causa de la pandemia aquí
vamos a defender
[Música]
una crisis económica sin precedente de
la que culpan al actual presidente lenin
moreno y demandan volver al viejo modelo
político
porque se trabaja con el señor
que se ha asesorado por el señor correa
porque si fue un señor hay muchas
personas que están tratando de después
de esta pandemia recuperar lo que es el
comercio entonces sí sería muy bueno que
les ayude para así poder fomentar otra
vez lo que es su capital su ingreso para
seguir pues en el día a día
del otro lado de ir a hacer el programa
social de andrés araus es cuestionado
por su principal contendor el candidato
de derecha y banquero guillermo lasso es
una propuesta en el aire hueca con
dinero que no le pertenece al gobierno
ese dinero del banco central le
pertenece a los depositantes de la banca
a las a los municipios a las prefecturas
y al sistema de seguridad social del
ecuador por lo tanto ese no es un dinero
de propiedad del gobierno el actual
presidente del inh moreno también se
presentó como partidario de rafael
correa antes de su giro político
que con andrés araos aseguran no
repetirán
la empresa minera brasileña vale acordó
pagar una multa de 5 mil 700 millones de
euros unos siete mil millones de dólares
al estado de minas gerais dos años
después del colapso de una presa que
dejó 170 muertos la rotura de esta presa
del complejo minero de bailén desató un
torrente de desechos mineros que
contaminó todo a su paso
veamos el siguiente informe
el derrumbre de la represa de desechos
mineros en brumadinho cubrió un
equivalente a 300 campos de fútbol con
lodo tóxico y mató a 270 personas dos
años después el propietario de la presa
el gigante minero vale anunció que
pagaría cinco mil setecientos millones
de euros por daños al estado de minas
gerais
vale se compromete a reparar y compensar
íntegramente los daños causados por la
tragedia de brumadinho y a contribuir
cada vez más a la mejora y desarrollo de
las comunidades en las que operamos
confiamos en que este acuerdo global sea
un paso importante en esta dirección
el gobierno estatal solicitó
originalmente 8 mil 400 millones de
euros y dijo que la cantidad acordada
era sólo una estimación inicial el
acuerdo está destinado a cubrir los
daños socioeconómicos y medioambientales
al estado e incluye unos 1.400 millones
de euros en indemnizaciones directas a
las víctimas sin embargo las familias de
los afectados rechazaron el acuerdo y
prometieron demandar por una cantidad
mayor ahora las casas están abandonadas
en brumadinho y los lugareños aseguran
que la ciudad todavía necesita ayuda
desesperadamente es acorde a la para mí
no me importa el acuerdo quiero que me
compensen por mi propiedad porque esto
ya no es un lugar para vivir
que para mí que el lugar programa es que
haya un poco y les pedimos que vivir en
el lugar ya hemos sufrido mucho por esta
tragedia aquí junto con esa tragedia
el acuerdo no cubre los cargos penales
relacionados con el desastre los
fiscales han acusado a 16 personas
incluido el ex presidente de vélez de
homicidio intencional y delitos
medioambientales alegando que ocultaban
el riesgo de colapso que tenía la presa
aunque en el pasado ya se vivieron otras
roturas de presas en las que se acusó al
sector minero esta será la primera en
contar con una indemnización importante
en brasil
el presidente francés amará el macro ni
la canciller alemana angela merkel
tendrán una reunión virtual de consejos
de defensa y seguridad hoy viernes y se
espera que los dos líderes aborden la
represión rusa contra la oposición será
su primera reunión oficial desde que yo
bailé se convirtió en el presidente de
eeuu lo que cambia la relación entre los
miembros de la otan vamos hasta parís
allí se encuentra a natalia ruiz natalia
muy buen día que se espera de esta
reunión
sí muy buenos días pues esta reunión
está por comenzar y hay bastantes temas
sobre la mesa el primero hacer las
relaciones con eeuu justamente cuando yo
bailen pues se ha dicho en su discurso
de política exterior que quiere volver a
reconstruir los lazos con sus aliados
también van a hablar de la soberanía
europea esto es decir a la seguridad del
continente que para angela merkel pues
debe ser asegurada por la otan mientras
que para emanuel el marco en realidad la
idea es que europa pues se pueda
garantizar ella sola esta seguridad y
derecho esto nos hace recordar cuando se
realizó esta misma reunión en 2019 y
justamente antes de esa reunión en ese
momento de manuel marco había dicho que
la otan estaba de muerte cerebral algo
que no le había gustado para nada la
canciller alemana el tercer tema que van
a discutir durante este día es el de
armamento es un tema bastante delicado
ahí también porque ambos países
iniciaron un proyecto conocido como
staff que es el sistema de combate
para el futuro un proyecto que comenzó
en el 2017 pero que hasta ahora pues no
ha podido avanzar de verdad no ha tenido
un bueno progreso porque ha tenido
muchos inconvenientes por una parte para
que se vote el presupuesto de este
proyecto por parte de ambos países y
también por cuestiones industriales pero
bueno la idea es que hablar de este tema
justamente antes de que angela merkel
pues se deje de ser la canciller en
septiembre así es natalia gracias por la
información ustedes también gracias
continúan con nosotros esto es france24
[Música]
en un instante moda